there can be any number of reasons
behind current labor shortages and skill
shortages both on the demand and the
supply side mobility and movement of
people leaving the country leaving the
area you have a demand for a whole lot
of new skills that aren't yet out there
in the labor market the right kind of
training isn't available or isn't being
offered one of our main missions as a
public employment service is to match
the demand and the offer on the labour
market and what we really saw during the
last years is that the skills gap
continuously increased you have failures
in the recruitment infrastructure there
isn't enough knowledge about current and
future skill requirements the challenge
is that we don't really have good data
on the skills that employers need
especially in real time so we use tax
mining to extract this data and it
really allows us to get in a couple of
hours
millions of skills identified
for the hundreds of thousands of job
vacancies that that we have in
luxembourg we have a public private
partnership culture that is established
we work as uel very closely together
with adam we have a partnership for
employment where we tried in the
beginning to focus more on getting
people into work now since recently we
focus on the skills gap i used to work
as a senior assistant
and i was made redundant i registered to
adam and they talked to me about their
future skills i did
six months at the university of
luxembourg and after that applied for a
position within the uni and now i've
been working there for a month the
effective labor shortages is that
employers can't provide new services
tender for new opportunities and in the
end their business could fail yeah in
slovenia like in many other european
countries we have many labor shortages
on one hand we think we have enough
unemployed people but the biggest
problem is that these people aren't
skilled for the particular jobs or in
the particular sectors so that's why we
see those labor shortages in sectors
such as manufacturing or tourism
hospitality especially in the last two
years obviously there were shortages
prior to covet 19. now as we are
emerging a little bit from the pandemic
you get new shortages where workforce
might have left on mass because those
sectors were closed we were struggling
for a while because a lot of employees
wanted to change
completely the industry
and this is where we again we turn to
employment services they support us with
on-the-job training we can hire
young people making them trained
employees when they start most of the
people trained through the on-the-job
training got employed in these sectors
at latest one year after the job
training helped me to start a
professional career in the hotel as a
trainee and after that i got a full-time
job i'm planning to finish my faculty of
economics
department marketing
and maybe
i will work with the marketing team here
in the hotel i hope so
i think by working with other
stakeholders you can
draw on their experience and knowledge
and their additional data as well in
order to build a better package of
measures that actually helps to
integrate someone into work